[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir
il ya même des gens là bas bonsoir j'ai
eu dix minutes mais c'est vrai que
j'aime bien prendre le temps de faire
connaissance avec le public avant de
démarrer un vous êtes bien c'est vrai
faut le dire waouh
non non c'est vrai en même temps faut
dire que c'est surtout la salle qui vous
met en valeur le lieu est sympa ah ouais
vraiment super un rat il ya une coulisse
ici il y en a une autre de l'autre côté
à aa et peut-être que même ici aussi ana
il n'y a pas de bon de sortie
moi je vais peut-être pas sortir par là
du coup à la fin sûrement pas mais enfin
je sais pas j'ai pas encore décidé on
verra le lâcher prise
moi j'ai pas l'habitude parce que je
joue dans des caves
ouais alors c'est pour ça que je suis
assez impressionné quoi les caf c'est
comme le café théâtre mais en pire
ah ouais on à l'opéra le théâtre
le café théâtre les caves et les égouts
c'est vrai que je me suis longuement
interrogé sur les raisons qui me
poussent à monter sur scène
certains le font par besoin de
reconnaissance ils ont été méprisés dans
leur enfance étant une revanche sur la
vie en se faisant applaudir souvent dans
des caves ou comme ce soir au théâtre
moi personnellement je le fais par amour
pour les autres pardon de moi-même pour
vous apporter du bonheur et donner un
sens à votre vie
ma plus belle récompense c'est quand à
la fin du spectacle le public vient me
voir pour me dire alexandra merci
grâce à toi je sais enfin qui je suis je
leur réponds voir louis c'est génial
parce que moi je ne sais pas du tout qui
tu es mais je suis contente que tu te
sois enfin trouvé donc pour vous
apporter du bonheur et donner un sens à
votre vie
j'ai décidé d'aborder un sujet qui me
tient à coeur
un sujet que je trouve des plus
excitants mois vous pouvez applaudir
merci dis donc toi je te sens pas hyper
emballé par le sujet un petit conseil
apprend à recevoir ce qu'on te donne un
soin dans l'acceptation d'accord je
prends ce qu'on te donne tu prends
d'accord tu verras tu verras je t'assure
tu verras et ce qui est valable pour lui
est valable pour tout le monde
1 alors je vais commencer par le début
je viens du chili alors on pour ceux qui
manquent de culture générale
le chili c'est en amérique latine
d'accord donc vous avez sous les yeux un
spécimen tout à fait étonnant me
indienne me bombe latine
tu me diras merci à la sortie du
spectacle dakar je pense que je me suis
assez bien intégrés dans la société
française j'aime le bon vin le bon
fromage les bons antidépresseurs aussi
et comment vous dire ça va ça valait
jane va faire du social ça va la
jeunesse oui bon ça fa la coupe super tu
sais que là je peux te te tailler
vraiment et y a personne ici qui va
venir t'aider
bonjour
sèche peut te liévin n'essaye pas de
partir discrètement non plus parce que
c'est mal barré
donc alors ah oui ma citation préférée
c'est celle de che guevara qui a dit je
préfère mourir debout que vivre à genoux
c'est fort ma deuxième citation préférée
c'est celle de nabila qui a dit oui mais
quand on meurt après c'est foutu c'est
fort
incroyable mes parents étaient très
militant ils ont lutté contre pinochet
le dictateur chilien voilà donc c'est
vrai que j'ai eu une enfance un peu
particulière on peut dire ça comme ça
oui parce que moi le soir pour
m'endormir ma mère elle ne chantait pas
une berceuse toi ta mère elle te chanter
une berceuse à elle peut chanter une
chanson par exemple un champ vers lui
avouez vous êtes donc pour toi aussi
c'est compliqué
ben moi ma mère par exemple elle me
chanter pour m'endormir le soir et tout
est blanc ou nul au hamas et l'a 26
bonne nuit ma chérie alors l'équivalent
ici c'est macron démission d'anne
questions macro dit alexandra chante
avec moi ma grande émission macron
démission bonne nuit ma chérie fais de
beaux rêves avec che guevara il fidèle
cas toujours sur le chemin de la liberté
en laissant la mélanine soumissionnent
philippe thomas chéri
du coup je suis devenu un peu militante
par la force des choses
faut le dire alors je mène mais petit
combat ouais il ya un combat qui me
tient particulièrement à coeur c'est la
famine à travers le monde
je suis contre contre contre vraiment je
rejette l'idée
alors pour lutter contre la famine à
travers le monde
je me suis dit tiens il faut que tu
achètes un petit carnet pour noter
toutes tes petites idées
ah bah il faut bien commencer alors
alors je vais à monoprix viendra je suis
comme ça moi mais quand je décide de
mener ma lutte givet quoi monoprix
direction monoprix alors bon je prends
ma trottinette
je vais à monoprix je fasse je là je
vais à monoprix comme ça en tout en
trottinette je vais à monoprix
j'arrive à monoprix toi arrive à
monoprix déterminer ah ouais
elle est comme ça la vie bon j'arrive à
je saute de ma trottinette je je je je
creuse un trou pour mettre ma
trottinette à l'intérieur je creuse un
trou tu y vas tu sais pas pourquoi mais
j'ai creusé un trou pour mettre votre
ordinateur
je creuse un coup de main à la toile de
voir le trou je creuse le trou de même
un pas ce que j'ai fait du théâtre
je voudrais que ça se voit je creuse
comme ça je rentre - après je rentre à
nous non plus comme ça je cherche la
vendeuse je cherche la vendeuse je
cherche avant 2 et parce qu'en plus j'ai
dix minutes à faire je cherche avant de
gérard gélas monde je cherche la
vendeuse ah je vois la vente de jardin
pas la vendeuse elle comprend tout de
suite de la elle à l'urgence de la
situation ou quoi je lui dis je cherche
un cahier pour sauver l'humanité
quelques ayem conseillez vous est ce
qu'à votre avis je dois prendre un
cahier avec des petits ou des grands
carreaux et là elle me répond aux grands
maux les grands carreaux mais c'est toi
clairefontaine
diplômé d'oxford elle a fait l'ena du
cahier la femme est super compétent tu
peux te lever pourquoi on te voit
lève toi oui toi voix oui clairefontaine
supergrave et je me suis en fait depuis
le monoprix elle vraiment contente de
dire merci tu peux être à soi c'est
marrant parce que j'ai une amie qui est
un peu comme moi exceptionnel dans la
générosité le partage l'échangé vous
voyez c'est marrant parce que c'est
toujours quand on prend le métro qu'elle
veut me parler de ces histoires de cul
tu as déjà su c'est un mec sur une aire
d'autoroute
sur une aire d'autoroute alors moi je
réfléchis à l'augmentation basse était
pas vraiment une aire d'autoroute mais
ce que je sais c'est donc c'était dans
la voiture l'aaa oui c'était avec le mec
david de monoprix de vraiment vers votre
recul on peut dire que vraiment c'est
non et toi ouais mon cousin
mais c'était pâte à pain
alors là bas moi je lui montre que je
compatis dans le métro avec la vieille
dame à côté et la petite fille de 8 ans
c'est demain et récemment elle s'est
inscrite sur un site de rencontres oui
pour trouver des plans cul tu fait
j'entends pas j'espère entendu tu veux
si tu veux dire c'est une île mais
l'ambiance est bien il faut l'être
c'est peut-être des futurs rois du
groupe assez jeune
onze mois après si tu veux que je te
fais un autographe
donc mon ami qui est un peu comme moi
quelqu'un d'exceptionnel donc elle s'est
inscrite sur un site de rencontres voilà
pour trouver des plans chacun son truc
et un jour elle m'appelle bon elle avait
eu une panne de qu une peine de cul
bouchez vous les oreilles
c'est comme une peine de coeur mais pour
les plans cul alors moi je lui dis mais
vas-y dix mois tout je suis à l'écouté
je les écoute je suis dans le partage et
l'échangé jeudi mais vas-y dix mois tout
dis moi tout ce que tu as sur le cul
elle me dit enfin en fait elle avait
rencontré quelqu'un un mec ce qu'ils
cherchent une relation stable et
sérieuse un mec bien
tu te rends compte il m'a manipulé il
m'a fait croire qu'ils avaient une femme
deux enfants en fait j'apprends coin
j'apprends quoi le mec
en fait il est en instance de divorce 1
et il veut me comblez d'amour jusqu'à la
fin de mes jours l'enculé dire que j'ai
ouvert mon document car mon coeur pardon
et je pense que je vais m'arrêter là
parce que ce sketch devient vu le gars
et pour ceux qui le pensent vraiment
j'ai envie de vous dire oui mais la vie
est vulgaire
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
pas de big n
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]